hey should we start to show over no I
think this is how I was doing I like
mixing no big thing yeah and I like it
when it's like lized
just disheveled you're the place on your
podcast you have a structure you do have
a producer I have a producer to it this
fall guy has a pink dick yeah I know but
you know I like it what it's a little
chaotic you know I love it this shows
been so much fun I know but can I just
say this so um I haven't been on yours
I've asked you froggy you have never
asked me and that's you know what I'm
gonna say this I swear to God Bobby can
I tell you what your roll up your text
messages yeah no because it's a new
phone so you always said your number why
let me tell you something yeah should I
tell you something I'm pretty sure you
ladies you ready yes Bobby will lie and
believe his life yeah believe it to the
to the point where he'll cry like tears
and sell it to you we've talked about it
on here he is a great great liar yeah
great liar and he believes his life so
much so now it's a truth now it's a real
deal yeah it's like Oh Jay it's like
okay it's not like okay it's like okay
no Jane Oh Jay honestly thinks he didn't
murder the entire house like Oh Jay it
is like Oh Jay kill the white [ __ ] in
of the guy that waiter a waiter but I
guarantee if you did I would lie upon
lie about it and you would get away with
it yeah don't increment yourself yeah
ma'am so when I tell people I was at
Pearl Harbor oh they people I believe
that you believe you were at Prague
because Ryan is easy to the 9/11 thing
so I've been doing Pearl Harbor and
people don't know you were there I was
there man I was sleeping in the bunker
Pearl Harbor Hawaii 1944 t90 40 40 I go
yeah and I heard the kamikaze is it
coming down man
and then my black friend who looks like
Cuba Gooding jr. had a little [ __ ]
machine gun all right he was a chef any
you know what but no I have told people
that and I have lied a lot I lie about
things a lot yeah you're right but you
know what you can show him a text
message yeah by this roof yeah exhibit a
Exhibit B Exhibit C and he's like I did
not write that yeah yeah what yes yeah I
could be like Bobby why did you text
this to this person and they're like
that's not my phone and you like that's
not he'll come I texted caps yeah those
are lowered hey is that is that a
character D flaw what the way you're
speaking yes just your teeth missing she
said six and everyone knows your mouth
it's her do I know how many teeth he's
got like six missing in the back row
come on let's fix this
I can't you find what your public figure
is fine I - but my front smile and look
to the right smile look to the right you
can't see it smaller looks to the right
cup yeah we gotta fix that because they
were like I'm gonna mix raise money nose
your show right I don't have the money
right starter I can [ __ ] face like
like every two thousand dollars we put
like a tooth that says two thousand cuz
there was they said that they were gonna
have to drill like oh yeah that's like
I'm not doing that I should get it into
the skull part of her skull up her skull
upper gum gum yeah into the bone yes and
then they screw it in is that a jaw can
you just google it yeah yeah well you
upper channel - man yeah but he has a
computer that on you dick okay god they
call the maxilla ma xio that's what
maxilla which is the meat that you serve
at your restaurant maxilla thousand uh
slice
lies so I do like I do and that's a
character defect I'm gonna change that
myself yeah yeah
you should do that your image you are
who you are makes life more yes life
motto is light a win yes
lie to win
[Music]